so richard had a van when he was in high
school and he convinced his parents to
let him trick out the van and live in it
and then richard was telling me he cut a
hole in the floor of the van
because if he had to take a [ __ ] he just
put like a little plastic seat over the
hole and then he would drive off and
like like for the next couple of days
he'd drive by his [ __ ] to see what was
going on with it oh my god
it was actually the passenger seat was a
toilet i found a a guy in a neighboring
town had a toilet on his porch for a
long time
and i've just stopped one day i was like
how much you want for that toilet and he
sold it to me for like five bucks and i
bolted it
onto the passenger side of the van there
was no speed there and we cut a hole
with a welding torch in the bottom
and
so when i got into this van there was
the driver's seat
and then to your right was instead of
the uh passenger seat it was a toilet
yes
yeah and you cut a hole
and so like if
if i'm your friend and i'm out like
you'd go to a party you'd be drinking
and if you had to take a [ __ ] rather
than you just go into your van and [ __ ]
rather than them going out to [ __ ] in
the woods or something they would just
get in the passenger side of my van and
we'd watch them and watch their face
like with them grunting and stuff
we don't wait we've got lean down where
you see like at the bottom of the van
and we wait for the [ __ ] to pop onto the
ground and it was it was like
entertainment at a keg party did you uh
did you have toilet paper in there or
yeah yeah yeah i wasn't a heath total
ethan but yeah
cause it was either that or leaves but
yeah i'd carry toilet paper around and
uh sometimes we'd put ice in it and use
it for a cooler too but
like there'd be toilet streaks in there
yeah
look you'd have to really be careful
which beer you grabbed yeah but uh my my
buddy i had a 400 pound buddy that ended
up breaking the toilet
like sitting on it so you're kidding
yeah what would happen when you [ __ ] and
then you'd like drive by every day to
see what's happening with your [ __ ]
yeah i'd just drive by because you know
it was like on my way home from school
or something and i just go look to see
if an animal ate it or if somebody drove
through it like sometimes
sometimes there'd be like a tire mark
through it and i would laugh
sometimes there'd be like a bicycle tire
mark through some of them and i'd be
like oh my god that poor person that
rode their bike through there
so you would get out and examine you
couldn't tell this from yeah hey robin
look over there that van is taking a
[ __ ]
richard like driving by hey hey
look that my [ __ ] has flies on it now
look at that
this is fun